- Good morning Believe Nation,
today's message is "learn it all".
Over to you Tony Hawk.
(basketball bouncing)
(rooster crowing)
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
- What is it that makes you
a real special champion?
- I just, I never, well
for one I never quit.
I never stopped skating,
I never took a hiatus.
Say, five years and came back
like oh, skating's hot now
I'm going to get back into it.
So I have that consistency, but I think
that for me I really like
learning new techniques.
And a lot of people if they're skating
they stick with this one style of skating,
this one set of tricks and
don't want to branch out
because they're afraid they won't
look cool doing it or whatever.
I always wanted to try
the different techniques,
even if I stumbled on them
I knew that in the end
it would help me be more well rounded
and I think that's probably what it is
is that I wanted to try to learn it all.
- I think really important to understand
where innovation comes from.
If you're an entrepreneur
you want to come up
with these new innovative ideas.
You want to break through in your market,
have something that's really different,
understand where innovation
comes from because
most of the time
innovation just comes from
connecting the dots that other
people haven't seen before.
By looking at different industries,
different businesses, different cultures,
and seeing how things work there,
way over here that
nobody's thought of before,
not even on camera,
and bringing it back to what you're doing.
Steve Jobs famously came up with fonts
in the personal computing industry
and that's what helped sell
his first line of computers.
But Steve Jobs wasn't the first
person to think about fonts,
and the importance of
writing and writing style,
and the impact that that has.
He just took a well known
science that people acknowledged
the importance and relevancy
of it and just brought it
to this new field of computers over here.
He just lined up those two things
that nobody had connected
those dots before.
That's what you need to do.
This is where you have the ability
to really stand out from
everybody else around you.
By connecting the dots of
the things that you love
that nobody else has those
combinations of love.
I love business.
I love YouTube.
I love League of Legends.
I love the Toronto Bluejays, and baseball.
I love salsa dancing.
I combined all of these things
into a business that
nobody else can replicate.
It's why you can't out-Evan, Evan.
It's why when people just copy me
for exactly what I'm doing,
they're never going to win.
They're not going to innovate.
They're just copy cats.
I don't care about the copy,
I don't look behind.
I don't care about blocking
the copy cat people.
I'm looking forward, and
you need to do the same.
All of your interests,
all of your passions,
everything that you've ever liked,
you can combine all those ideas to make
an amazing, unique, different,
special, valuable business.
When I took over Toronto Dance Salsa
at the beginning of
this year as the owner,
I brought a whole bunch of
things to the salsa industry
that has never been seen before.
I'm bringing aspects of
YouTube and entrepreneurship
and baseball and League of Legends,
and all the things that I care about,
into this business that
nobody else can replicate.
'Cause they don't have the same passions.
And if they're just trying to
copy me they're going to fail.
The way for them to win is to
go more in on their strengths
and the things that they care about
and find a way to integrate
that into their business.
This is how you are going
to win as an entrepreneur.
Stop trying to copy everybody else.
Find the connective tissue
between seemingly unrelated
industries, hobbies, passions,
and find a way to make it work.
Combine the genius of the and.
That's where you're going to have success.
Do it now!
Think about what you love to do,
what your hobbies are,
what your passions are,
that people might think is
weird or different or odd.
How you spend your spare time,
where you like to go on vacation.
What can you pull from all of those things
to instantly make your business better?
Figure that out.
You've got some magic ingredients
for an amazing business.
So the questions of the day today is
I'm curious, what have you learned
from a different industry
that seemed totally irrelevant,
but then you applied it to your business
and it worked?
Super curious to find out,
leave it in the comments below,
I'm going to join in the discussion.
I also want to gie a quick
shoutout to Brittany Robinson
from treehousedreampublishing.com.
Brittany thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
Your One Word, it really,
really, really means a lot to me.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is, much love,
and I'll see your tomorrow
morning for another
shot of Entspresso.
♫ I wake up every mornin'
♫ Entspresso keep me goin'
Hey Believe Nation, we're also looking at
making a top ten of Tony Hawk.
Here's a quick sneak peak of some of
the clips we're thinking of including.
I hope you enjoy, let
me know what you think.
- When I started our company, Birdhouse,
in the first three years in
we were ready to give in.
You know, the sales just weren't there,
the interest wasn't there.
And same with my skating,
like I was still improving my skills
but for no audience.
So it was definitely difficult,
but we embraced those challenges too,
and especially as athletes,
I mean, someone poses a challenge to you
and you have to figure
out how to get over it.
And so in doing that in my
skating and also in the business
it was like, well this
is what's coming at us
we've got to figure out
how to navigate this
and how to succeed, and a
lot of people just give up.
And especially in skating, I mean,
that's the first sign of someone
that's going to be successful.
No matter how far, no matter
how successful they get,
especially in competition,
they continue to challenge themselves
because they want to improve.
Those are the guys that make it
way further than anyone else.
- When you're coming up with a new idea
for your sport, what is it that you,
how do you get into the zone,
then translate that
into the business world?
How do you come up with that next step,
the next innovation
that's going to put you
once again out in front of everybody else?
- I think it's having the confidence.
When I approach something,
say just a new trick,
I know I have the skills,
the inherent skills to do it.
I know that I visualized
it and I know I can do it.
Same goes for business, you know,
I know, like we did a tour,
it's called "Boom Boom HuckJam",
Karl Harris was a big part of that,
he's here in the audience.
We did a tour, which was
skating, BMX, motocross.
I visualized the whole thing.
I said you know, we have,
our sports are popular enough
that we don't have to be a side
show to Warped Tour anymore.
We don't have to be the half
time show to the football game.
We can get our own crowd.
We can be the headliner of an arena tour.
And I designed the ramps
on, stupid me, on a napkin.
Cost a million bucks.
(audience laughs)
And it filled the arena floor.
It included motocross, skateboard and BMX.
I just knew that that would work
and I knew that there
were enough kids out there
that would love to come see a show.
It was our sports as entertainment,
it wasn't about competition.
It was actually my transition from
being a competitor to being a performer.
And I never thought what
if this doesn't work?
What if it sucks?
What if no one comes?
Like, that's what kills you,
because you live in that world of doubt
and it comes to fruition.
And you can't think that way,
just if you know it's
something that you love
and you instinctually
think it's going to work
then you have to go at
it and say it will work,
and see it through.
And sometimes it takes years.
I get so busy I forget to stop and say
wow I'm actually living the dream.
And I think that for all of you guys,
going to college and
aspiring to do something,
you'll find yourself completely busy
and overwhelmed at times,
and if you just stop
and look around and go wow
I'm actually doing this,
you know this is kind
of what I had in mind.
It's just that you get so
caught up in the whirlwind of it
you don't realize that,
you got to just stop
and think wow this is it, I appreciate it.
I wanted to figure out
how I could remove myself
from competition and still be a pro skater
and that had not been done yet.
Because if you're not going to compete,
the magazine's not going to cover you,
your sponsors are likely to drop you,
and the kids who are buying your products
are going to forget about you.
And there was no such thing
as a video skater back then
that hadn't really come into play yet.
There was no YouTube, you
know, the skate videos
were usually based on the
best guys in the competitions.
And so I went and talked to Stacy, and--
- Who was you boss at the time.
- Stacy Peralta was my coach,
and I actually had my brother
some with me as backup
and he approached Stacy and said,
"Look, Tony's really having a
problem with the competitions.
"It's kind of wrecking him.
"It's ruining the fun of skating."
And I told him that and so he said,
"Well, you know, I understand,
"and maybe you might want to take a break,
"but don't give it up completely.
"'Cause you may want to come back,
"you may enjoy it, and I
don't know if we're going
"to be able to sustain your career
"if you're not competing."
And I did take a break, I
stopped competing for a while,
almost a year, maybe a little less.
And when I came back
to it, I came back with
sort of a fresh perspective
that I don't really care how it lays out.
I'm going to go and do my best,
and I'm going to take chances
that I maybe hadn't taken before,
and if that puts me in
last place, then so be it.
But if I succeed, then I'm going to be
on this whole other level of skating.
And that's what happened.
I mean, and the contest that I won then,
I won by a long shot, you know,
'cause I was doing stuff
that was experimental,
and stuff that I wasn't
really confident with,
but I could pull it through somehow.
And if it didn't happen then
I didn't do well at all.
And I stopped caring about
the end result so much.